vingt-quatre heures à voir
l'affrontement contre les grands rivaux
de pau ce temps on pouvait toujours se
procurer de bonnes paires de billets au
centre bell sans avoir à passer par les
revendeurs le match c'est quand même
joué à guichet fermé mais il semble plus
facile ces jours ci ne se procurer des
places pour voir la sainte flanelle
lorsque les équipes professionnelles
dans le sport ont des périodes creuses
you généralement immédiatement une
réaction du public qui fait en sorte que
le produit est moins séduisant
oui lalonde et l'ancien vice président
marketing des canadiens on lui doit
toutes les cérémonies entourant le
centenaire de l'équipe
il est aujourd'hui consultant dans le
secteur du sport et des affaires
c'est clair qu'une équipe qui gagne et
une économie qui est très forte et
solide fait en sorte que le produit se
vend beaucoup plus rapidement que ce
soit une loge de soins bio de saison que
ce soit un billet pour un match régulier
or actuellement les sept équipes
canadiennes ne gagne pas et malgré
l'arrivée d'un nouvel entraîneur très
réputé toronto croupit toujours dans les
bas fonds du classement
ça fait en sorte que ya plus de chance
et de billets disponibles que jamais
dans le passé pour les mais pour les
autres
à winnipeg la presse locale rapportaient
qu'il était récemment possible d'acheter
jusqu'à 16 places assises côte à côte le
sport professionnel ses ventes de
l'espoir aux amateurs côté pas beaucoup
d'espoir on a plus de chances d'avoir
des sièges vides
or avec notre dollar qui est en forte
baisse les équipes canadiennes ont bien
choisi leur moment pour sous performer
car les dépenses des propriétaires sont
en dollars américains et avec le taux
change les joueurs coûtent chaque jour
un peu plus cher pique et souvent par
exemple ils gagnent 9 millions de
dollars américains par année à la
signature du contrat
jeff monson devaient débourser 9
millions huit cent mille dollars
canadiens pour le pays avec la pèze la
devise le 9 millions américains de
subban coûte actuellement plus de 13
millions de dollars canadiens au bac la
différence en moins de profits mais les
quais votre profiteurs domaine en effet
personne ne va pleurer sur le sort des
kits milliardaire pomme
le canadien ou encore les mets police
mais une exclusion des scieries combinée
à la dévaluation du dollar pourrait
faire très mal aux plus petits marchés
comme winnipeg dans les petits marchés
en et air très très accroché à la roue
revenus du che c'est très très important
beaucoup plus que dans les plus grands
marchés montréal c'est un grand marché
et à la télé il ya les produits dérivés
a beaucoup beaucoup de choses qui font
que le canadien de montréal est viable
reste qu'au final c'est un peu toute la
ligue nationale qui subit la chute du
dollar canadien au canada il ya cette
équipe dans la ligue nationale de hockey
qui génère près ou plus de 40% de tous
les revenus des 30 hic c'est les sept ne
se qualifiait pas ces images in d'abord
l'impact sur l'or qui à la télévision au
canada
les commanditaires investisseurs dans le
rock kid à l'hymne national au canada
la dernière fois qu aucune équipe
canadienne n'a fait les séries c'était
en 1970 les plus optimistes diront que
la saison n'est pas encore terminée
ici vincent maisonneuve radio-canada bon